Tụi tập trận với tên lừa đảnh đạo li lục điện giao squo nghe
Xin xa tại các cư dưa scour là
Lâm những trứng trường tiến trị lượng mà mắt cơ vai đập vào lực lượng xâm đeạn như cơ đạo
Hãy thông dào s có khả năng măng như đồ đạn phần hướng
Và vượt qua cây thống phòng thủ
Hẹn là sương sống của lực lượng xe bây mờ cơ đập của nghe
Được viện ký thuật nhiền mắt cơ vai phát triển
Hãy thông dào đồ biến trị từ cuối nhìn năm 2020
Bằng vệ trình khai các bệ phòng từ hành tổ chức hành quân trị thuật
Thế là bị trị giá chiến và thực hành ứng phó tình hùng đe gióa
Ngài đăng cùng cố năng lực tất chiến thủ nghiệp
Và khả năng xung sớt trong xung đồ thạp nhăn
Bối hệ thống tên lượng tỉ tiến
Cố nốc tầm thống rất đi mê của chiến cũng thông báo
Ngài đăng tập trung sản xuất khai màng nó tên lửa siêu và đa mỏ rest neck
Được chào là không thể bị đánh chàng
Nhưng một biểu tượng trường xương mạnh công nghệ cuối phòng nghe
Vinh gà đầy mạnh hiện dễ thạm nhân gửa đồng
Chào tầy sự chuyện dịch trị lượng
Nhằm năng cao khả năng phản lượng linh hoặc trong mỏ tịch bản xuống đột